was den impfstoff betrifft ich glaube es
geht mit der impfung schneller los als
wir vor einiger zeit gedacht haben und
das ist dann auch richtig so wir haben
viel geld bereitgestellt und es wird
dann ganz schnell geimpft werden die
vorbereitungen sind getroffen doch in
diesen jahren wir haben die vorbereitung
getroffen dass es noch im dezember
losgehen könnte wenn es möglich ist aber
nicht weil wir dann wie irgendein
potentat entscheiden es geht am 15
dezember zum beispiel los sondern weil
wir sagen wenn es losgehen kann wofür
alles getan wird dann sollte also das
ist gleichzeitig entschuldigte muss nur
einmal auf meinen dass es gleichzeitig
losgeht wie in den usa weil da wurde
heute vereint entscheidung die kann man
nur als autokrat treffen als jemand der
nicht sich an gesetze hält und nicht die
gesundheit der bürgerinnen und bürger im
blick wir sie mal dennoch hoffnung für
die selber wir können sagen dass es so
schnell gehen wird wie es überhaupt geht
und noch mal in ländern in dem politiker
entscheiden wann der impfstoff fertig
entwickelt ist sollte man nicht gerne
leben
ich glaube wir brauchen ein regelwerk
welche hygiene standards muss ein
gastronomischer betrieb ein kosmetischer
betrieb an ein sport eine
sporteinrichtung was an kulturbetrieb an
theater was für jene standards müssen
die erfüllen um auch unter pandemie
bedingungen jetzt öffnen zu können
wir brauchen eine öffnung perspektive
klare regeln
weil auch das sonst die akzeptanz der
maßnahmen auf dauer gefährdet
und natürlich müssen wir auch den
wirtschaftlichen schaden noch abfedern
und eine herzliche einladung an den
finanzminister ist natürlich immer die
frage neu zu klären wie können die
verluste des jahres 2020 auch
rückwirkend mit dem gewinn 20 1918
verrechnet werden ich glaube da haben
wir noch eine ungenutzte möglichkeit ja
wir müssen gruppen die besonders
geschützt werden müssen schützen aber
den eindruck zu erwecken dass mit
hygieneregeln in der gastronomie wir uns
die entscheidung für den november oder
die falsche entscheidung jetzt noch
einmal zu verlängern wie ich und herr
söder ja auch schon angedeutet haben
ersparen könnten
der ist falsch das ist wirklich ihre
führung von allen beteiligten und sie
sind auch schon wieder legen wodurch
durch den november
denn wir haben sehr umfassende maßnahmen
ergriffen die dazu geführt haben dass es
jetzt nicht mehr eine exponentielle
steigerung der infektionsrate gibt aber
die nicht gereicht haben
und wenn dann ihre vorschlag ist wir
sollen nur einfach uns alle noch mehr am
riemen reißen und klappt das schon dann
ist das einfach ein bisschen billigten
ich das sagen darf und es hilft auch
nicht wirklich in dieser großen
herausforderung aber wer jetzt dürfen
sie sich auch vor argumenten nicht
drücken sie haben gesagt will ich habe
in dieser zeit will ich was ich sage ist
sei einfach es sei widerlegt ja ich
glaube ich glaube dass im november wie
gute zahlen haben wegen der beschränkung
der kontakte
das heißt dass wir alle beschränkt sind
unserem kontakt auf andere haushalte das
hat eine auswirkung gehabt aber sie
müssten mal eine einzige
wissenschaftliche untersuchung vorlegen
das die schließung der gastronomie dort
wo die hygienestandards eingehalten
werden können oder die schließung eines
theaters oder museums das dass
irgendeine auswirkung auf das er haben
denn hier geschehen gehabt hat eine
solche untersuchung gibt es nun erste
chance zwei antworten darauf nicht zwei
antworten darauf erstmal gibt es
mittlerweile doch eine ganze reihe von
untersuchungen die sagen dass ein
infektionsgeschehen in der gastronomie
zum beispiel stattfindet selbst bei
beachtung von hygienevorschriften in die
usa sind solche untersuchungen
tschuldigung gemacht war aber dass das
argument die das argument überzeugt mich
jetzt nur nächstes gehört noch und die
zweite zahl die dazu ist und die sie
auch beachten sollten wenn sie mögen ist
dass wir knapp von 25 prozent der
infektion wissen wo sie her stammen von
75 prozent nicht deutschland fragt sich
was passiert mittwoch letzte woche hat
erheblichen zoff gegeben wissen sie
schon für welche maßnahmen sie sind ganz
klar wird es dort entscheidungen geben
auch sehr klare die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten diskutieren gerade
viel miteinander und auch mit der
bundesregierung haben ja jetzt bewusst
ein weg gewählt wo es jetzt erstmal ein
vorschlag von den ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten gibt der wird
uns sicher morgen erreichen
aber eines ist schon klar ist wird
angesichts der erfolge die wir mit den
maßnahmen im november haben
nicht reichen wir haben eine
verbesserung der situation hinbekommen
aber nicht genug und deshalb wird es
schon auch um verlängerung gehen